trong ngày 15 tháng chính, ông Rubio đã có cuộc gặp với thu tướng Israen bàn ra mình này tàn như hủ tại Zero Slime.
Cuộc sĩnh ra trong buối cạnh Israen đang tiếp tục chứng dịch trong lãi ha ma và đang chân bị đệ mạnh chứng dịch tại thành phố gà ra.
Vất biểu với bảo dưới, ông Rubio hình định người dân gà ra sĩnh đáng có được vấn đề tây sáng hơn, nhưng thĩnh cạnh này không thể sây ra,
chất ở khi nào ha ma bị xóa sổ.
Ông cho biết sẽ thả lợi với thu tướng này tàn như hủ về cái hoạt của Israen nhằm dành quyền giềm sóa thành phố gà ra,
của đồ thịt lương mất của giải ra ra, cũng như các bình đề của khu bữa tay, ông đã bạch tuynh bố của tầm dưới tròn,
năng ở chính ra ra tân kết thúc với việc chạp dò chức các công tyng và đầm bảo hôm nay không còn là mùi đe dọa.
Luyện quan tới Iran, hãy chừng mình đã tâm kế phố phía Israen về phía chỉ áp lực tù đàn, để ngâm chạp để hiền ra khách chiến dịch hiạp nhìn,
sau chất dịch của sự hủy tăng sổ vực qua, trước đó vào thằng sau, Israen đã thực hiện các cuộc tình công gàm xú mục tiêu trên lạnh thủ của Iran.
Chúng bỏ cuộc các cơ sử hình nhân, mình sau đó đã phía chất các cuộc tình công gàm xú mục tiêu.